let's talk about whoopi goldberg i
thought yesterday because we've been
talking a lot about the view when we
finished the show yesterday i thought to
myself dave maybe tomorrow we won't talk
about the crazy ladies of the view and
then the crazy ladies of the view chimed
in because the crazy ladies of the view
are doing their show on abc right at
this very minute 11 a.m eastern so i
can't watch it live thank god and i
don't recommend that anyone does so i
see these clips afterwards
anyway they it was the holocaust
memorial day and they were talking about
the holocaust and you would think that
they would be able to talk about the
holocaust without kind of denying while
the holocaust happened but that was just
a bit too much for miss whoopi goldberg
well also if you're going to do this
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no
it's not about racism
but it's it's not about race it's not
about race
because you it's about man's inhumanity
to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy
you're missing the point the minute you
turn it into race it goes down this
alley let's talk about it for what it is
it's how people treat each other it's a
problem it doesn't matter if you're
black or white because black white jews
uh it's how everybody eats each other so
is it
if you're uncomfortable if you hear
about mouse
should you be worried should your child
say oh my god i i i wonder if that's me
no that's not what they're going to say
they're going to say i don't want to be
like that well hopefully i want to be
cool yeah
most kids most kids they they don't want
to be cruel no they don't and we're
living you know we're living in an era
where people are are comparing vaccine
cars to the yellow stars where people
are comparing vaccinations to what anne
frank went through yeah so it is
necessary for kids to learn about what
we're talking about i'm trying to worry
about man's inhumanity to man however it
exposes itself i have to cut you off i
just want to say that mouse was banned
and it flew to top 20 of amazon's rules
last week
yes all right first off i feel like i
owe you guys an apology every time we
play a clip from the view actually
yesterday you may remember we were going
to show you a clip from rachel maddow on
msnbc and we had a little hiccup with
the computer there and i saw a lot of
people in the comments going dave we
want to thank your technical people for
being unable to show that clip because i
show you these people and they're all
bananas and yet we all know we have to
do it because we have to expose the
nonsense now first off i just want to be
very very clear about something because
i know we all rush to judge everybody we
all try to destroy and cancel everybody
i do not think whoopi goldberg is an
anti-semite in any way okay i don't as a
matter of fact i think her real name is
karen walker and one of the reason
reasons that she told chose the name
whoopi goldberg goldberg obviously being
a jewish name was because she was around
a lot of jewish people when she was
growing up she lived in the inner city
and there were a lot of jews and black
people that lived in similar
neighborhoods right by each other and
she was very influenced by jewish people
i have no doubt that whoopi goldberg
does not hold hatred in her heart to
jewish people but what you see in that
clip
is how confused
everyone gets because of wokism that
because she has chosen the woke ideology
as as her main ethos in life that this
is the set of beliefs that she puts
above everything else you can see how it
basically destroys any sensible way of
talking about anything
obviously
obviously everyone knows this like this
is like basic basic stuff the nazis
considered the jews another race they
did not consider them white right like
this is basic nazi 101
so she's confused there because she has
now racialized everything so to her race
can only mean something about skin color
i will i can't believe i'm going to do
it but i'm going to give joy behar a
little credit joy who has gone off the
deep end but at the beginning of that
clip when whoopi says this about race
that it wasn't about race it was about
man's inhumanity to man joy kind of was
like well it was because they did
consider them another race so joy i know
i've been hard on you lately lady but
you did kind of pull it through there
you did make some sense there so i just
want to be clear i do not think whoopi
is an anti-semite i don't think she
hates jews i don't think she holds
hatred in her heart she's very confused
about woke-ism and says all sorts of
awful things
but now after that and by the way it was
pretty great how they were playing the
outro music the whole time like you know
the producers were like you're with the
holocaust thing
anyway she went on stephen colbert last
night to kind of apologize and it sort
of was going well and then
i said that i i felt that the holocaust
wasn't about race
and people got very very very angry and
still are angry i mean i'm getting you
know all of the the mail from folks and
the very real anger because people feel
very differently
but i thought it was
a
salient discussion because
as a black person i think of race as
being something that i can see so i see
you and i know what race you are people
were very angry and they said no no we
are a race and i i understand i
understand i i felt differently i
respect everything everyone is saying to
me and i
you know i don't want to fake apologize
you know i i was i very upset about that
people are
misunderstood what i was saying when you
talk about uh
being a racist i was saying you can't
call this racism this was evil this
wasn't this wasn't based on the skin you
couldn't tell who was jewish they had to
delve deeply to figure it out have you
come to understand that the nazis saw it
as race
because they might like asking the nazis
they would say yes it's a racial issue
well see this is what's interesting to
me because the nazis lied
it wasn't they
they had issues with ethnicity
not with race because most of the nazis
were white people and most of the people
they were attacking were white people so
to me i'm thinking how can you how can
you say it's about race if you are
fighting each other so
it all really began because i said how
will children how will we explain to
children what happened in nazi germany
this wasn't
i said this wasn't racial
this was about white on white and
everybody said no no no it was racial
so she like sort of apologized there but
then at the same time
makes it clear that she still doesn't
understand the issues and that's what
wokism does
you've diluted every same conversation
into skin color because whoopi oddly and
i know you can't quite see it but maybe
you'll get there the ideology you've
chosen is the neo-racism so you view
skin color now as the defining thing
which is so unfortunate because you have
such an amazing career right like you
you're a great actress and a great
comedian and and you as far as i knew
were a pretty moderate person for your
entire life like a great actress ghost
molly you in danger girl like she was
great won the academy award i think she
was the first was she the first black uh
woman who won supporting actress in
ghost i think she was i think she was if
i'm not mistaken anyway whoopi i'm not
here to cancel you you're confused and i
think if you start not looking at the
world only through a racial lens i mean
just imagine when she said the thing
about you know it was white on white you
know what i mean so it couldn't have
really been about race it's like that
doesn't really make sense or it's about
it's really about the inhumanity that
humans can have towards inhumanity it's
not about race imagine if a white person
let's just say a uh
you know a right-leaning person was on a
talk show someone on fox news let's say
this tucker carlson fella was on
fox news and he was talking about
slavery with somebody and he said you
know slavery actually
wasn't really about race it was just
about humans in humanity towards other
humans
they would be going bananas at the view
they would be saying tucker carlson was
a white supremacist he's denying racism
he's denying the history of the united
states and
but what do you mean it's just about
humans and humans are mean to other
humans that's just how it is anyway i
think you see what's going on here
whoopee
come around enough for this already